come on babe  rise and shine let's get that beautiful  ass out of bed  you want cereal what's it take I please  get a room sorry  none of this is real  none of this is real  all these memories were imprinted  my name is Alice Alice how nice to see  you again  what the hell is going on here we have  you under all control  they used me to perfect the fires  everyone I've ever known  I receive every time  it's being used against me  taking manipulatable now we've taken  over New York Moscow Tokyo this is  humanity's last stand  the beginning of the end  good luck you'll need it  umbrellas more powerful than ever  and we're the only ones  can stop them  all right waiting for a written  invitation sweet ride  you